by my watch 48 hours left
in trump's presidency and uh there have
been reports that trump has basically
given up his presidential duties not
doing much
but there is one area where trump
apparently has been working very hard
issuing pardons that's right he's
scheduled to issue at least 100 pardons
and commutations on his last full day in
office
and apparently that's just for starters
check out this clip
of trump speaking to some of his
die-hard supporters just this afternoon
i pardon a lot of terrific people but
guess what
i'm just getting warmed up it's a pardon
balloosa
[Applause]
there are some more people i'm gonna
pardon before i go
bernie madoff o.j simpson cannibal cop
it's a disgrace how they treated the
cannibal cop
i'm pardoning martin shkreli
bean dad ivan drago
those little stickers they put on apples
and to everyone who's been canceled
you're uncanceled
get back to work crystallia we need more
of your beautiful
jokes and that's not all
look under your seat every person in
this audience
is pardoned and now
check out the jumbotron for even more
spartans and guess what i've hidden
thousands of other pardons inside the
capitol building
just run in there and get them think
he's overdoing it a little bit
but uh anywho